oui bonsoir à tous on est en projo
regarde la montée des marches là et j'ai
des voisins pas très très commode
ils veulent se concentrer on aimerait se
concentrer mais des paillettes et Pas de
pantalon c'est rude on peut pas mettre
France 5 plutôt j'ai le plaisir immense
de
te servir à dors
[Applaudissements]
donc vous pouvez faire une interview
d'une heure sans note bah oui
heureusement
il y a toujours un truc qui vous vient
pour ben oui pourquoi vous êtes secs de
temps en temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année le pays a été traversé par
une contestation historique extrêmement
puissante unanime de la réforme des
retraites la marchandisation de la
culture que le gouvernement néolibéral
défend est en train de casser
l'exception culturelle française
c'est un gros Caire large
[Rires]
bon on n'est pas par là Karine je vous
en supplie une sortie que n'a pas
beaucoup apprécié la ministre de la
Culture qui s'est fendu dans tweet dans
la foulée je suis estomaqué par son
discours si un juste ce film n'aurait pu
voir le jour sur notre modèle français
de financement qui permet une diversité
unique au monde ne l'oublions pas
celle-ci me plaît beaucoup moi c'est à
la suite d'une délibération à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le calibrage
des œufs le Journal Officiel aurait
diffusé un texte avec une erreur
d'impression et le mot coquille s'est
retrouvé avec une lettre en moins et la
lettre qui manquait c'était le cul donc
je vous laisse imaginer ce que ça
donnait et donc et donc c'était dans le
potage dans ces cas-là c'est ça
moi j'ai 13 ans est-ce que tu aimerais
bien coucher avec moi c'est ça et à
l'époque vous aviez poussé un coup de
gueule c'est ça et en fait ce qui s'est
passé donc du coup
déjà une actrice porno qui se permet de
de d'aller parent ça ne passe pas mais
j'avais reçu du coup des men des morts
de viol etc parce qu'en fait les gens
n'acceptaient pas ne voulaient pas voir
tout le monde c'était votre faute à vous
parce que vous étiez actrice porno
c'est celui qui qui dit bon quand on a
peur de quelque chose il faut le décrire
le plus objectivement possible donc par
exemple si l'expérience sexuelle vous
vous avez peur décrivez l'objectif
effectivement vous verrez que c'est rien
du tout c'est le frottement de deux
épiderme avec émission d'un liquide
gluant voilà bon c'est vrai que dit
comme ça bon ça fait maintenant moins
peur
que les parents je faisais des captures
d'écran les messages des gamins que
j'arrive et j'arrivais à retrouver les
parents j'ai envoyé les messages aux
parents en disant cette carte à votre
enfant et les parents ne répondaient
mais non mais pas c'est pas possible mon
enfant ne serait jamais ça les parents
sont dans le déni une seule seconde que
leur enfant ont encore une curiosité
aujourd'hui c'est la jet d'eau total
donc vous allez avoir des actionnaires
qui vont donc voter les politiques à
venir le but c'est de bloquer cet
assemblée générale
gros pollueur de la planète et de
dénoncer et de faire entendre ce message
là que ça stratégie climat n'en ai pas
une
elle fait quoi avec sa poussette c'est
pas possible cette femme tente de
traverser une rue totalement inondée
elle tombe on doit l'aider le drame a
été invité grâce à cet homme les
catastrophes sont là sauf qu'on a pas
voulu voir ces bruits de fond c'est dit
que c'était des choses totalement épars
et je crois qu'au menu des emmerdes
excusez-moi l'expression on en est à
l'apéro certains prennent l'avion pour
aller voir des volcans en éruption mais
parfois il suffit juste de prendre sa
voiture pour voir un tel spectacle
qu'est-ce que vous pensez
vous êtes de la merde merci à eux d'être
là merci à eux de de dénoncer
d'hypocrisie qu'il y a autour de ces
entreprises qui parlent de développement
durable à tous les coins de paragraphe
de ces plaquettes et qui en fait font
des projets comme hip-hop pour total ces
gens n'ont aucune espèce de morale ces
gens n'ont aucune espèce de de
considération pour les autres ni pour le
climat donc oui qu'il fasse ça merci ça
demande de pétrole au niveau mondial est
en croissance et que ceci n'est pas
totalement énergie qui répond à cette
demande d'autres le feront à notre place
ce n'est pas totale énergie seul qui va
décider quels sont les besoins de nos
clients même si nous pouvons agir par la
diversification de nos offres d'énergie
et tu m'as dit qu'il y avait pas d'avion
c'était très scolaire c'est normal il y
en a de plus en plus ils sont de plus en
plus bas mais voilà comme ça on les voit
bien qu'il faudrait faire selon vous
est-ce qu'on peut une météo des cons
mais déjà une météo des gens enfin je
sais pas
une météo des gens qui qui
en permanence sont dans le déni et
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire justement
on va en parler on va en parler
Jean-Michel depuis 20 ans ça n'a pas
bougé et c'est même effarant j'avais
entendu ce matin le soutien fort de
ferme de Sandrine Rousseau normal elle
est élu Europe Écologie Les Verts alors
est-ce que
sur les studios comment elle est venue à
cheval
on était dans les mêmes locaux elle va
mettre mais elle est venue comment
est-ce que parfois vous vous dites tiens
là c'était une réflexion de vieux con
est-ce que vous non là j'ai vu lever le
doigt mais en fait c'était je posais une
question à leur adresse
mais merci merci vraiment
certains journalistes mettaient au sont
les cibles d'attaques de plus en plus
virulentes sur les réseaux sociaux en
particulier ces attaques viennent donc
de climatosceptiques qui visent aussi la
météo France par exemple exemple de
message cité par Le Parisien cette
semaine quand vous n'êtes pas capable de
faire des prévisions correctes à J-1 on
peut douter de vos compétences sur vos
analyses conservant le réchauffement
climatique les forces de l'ordre ont
utilisé les gaz lacrymogènes l'une de
nos collègues LCI qui filmaient la scène
a été violemment expulsée par des
vigiles puis par des policiers nous
dénonçons évidemment cette atteinte à
notre mission d'informer
cet après-midi un texte déposé par des
investisseurs demandez à Total énergie
d'aller plus vite et plus loin texte
rejeté
changer les choses avec des bouquets de
roses changer les balles changer les
hommes avec des géraniums